fallout 4 has a really strong gameplay
and exploration system but its story
while strong initially becomes a
complete mess by the end of the game act
1 provides backstory and motivation for
the player while the ending is just
filled with contradictions
underdeveloped factions and quests that
are just laughably bad that's why today
i'm going to explain why so without
further ado let's get started so we
start fallout 4 just like any other game
in the series with a slideshow of the
world except in fallout's case it's
footage of pre-war america one thing
that's important to keep in mind is that
fallout 4 was a major evolution of the
franchise there were new implementations
that were added to make it easier for a
new audience to grasp this game is a lot
of players first introduction to the
series so some background knowledge may
be necessary so that the new players are
brought up to speed i honestly like this
cutscene a lot fawn has never really
disappointed to me when it comes to its
opening cinematics and fallout 4 is no
exception as it shows the beauty of
fallout pre-war by displaying those
technological advancements and all the
scientific breakthroughs that were
achieved during this time but it also
shows the problems of the world like how
jobs are being lost rapidly and how
natural resources are depleting it's
after this where we finally get to see
our main characters nate and nora most
of fallout's protagonists are quite bare
bones when it comes to their background
as a lack of one helps create a
character that the player wants to make
fallout 3 just gave the player the
background of a vault dweller whose
father escaped the vault and new vegas
gave the player the character's
profession of a courier all of these
games used the small knowledge of the
character's background as a base for the
overall story but fallout 3 and 4 had
that background be about the protagonist
family and the situations they find
themselves in as for the voice acting
lots of people had issues with this as
they preferred substituting it with
their own voice which continued to
strengthen their relationship of the
player and the character together but
for me personally i don't really mind
this continuing the trend of first
within this series it's the first time
we also get to see pre-war america the
only other time was during operation
anchorage of fallout 3 but that was in
the middle of a war and it didn't really
convey the lifestyle of the american
citizen before the bombs fallout 4's
intro was all about establishing to the
player what life was like prior to the
great war we could see the technological
advancements in play as we can interact
with the family's mr handy eunic
codsworth who's assisting with the
family in any way that he can like
brewing their coffee or taking care of
the baby we also get introduced to the
more grim side of the game as we can
hear a news broadcast about the ongoing
conflict between america and china and
we also get a visit from a vault-tec
representative who wants to sign us up
for the vault program since the creation
of nuclear bombs both china and america
have stockpiled hundreds of them ready
to launch whenever they want so
vault-tec created these vaults which
were made to keep the american people
safe just in case of a nuclear fallout
one thing that this intro has that may
not be apparent is tension as a
completely new player it seems just like
a normal intro to the game but to anyone
who's played fallout before you know
that the great war will be starting soon
you just don't know when maybe it'll
happen in game maybe it'll happen in a
cutscene maybe this intro is just a
dream regardless of what it could be the
bombs haven't dropped yet and at some
point they will and that creates immense
anxiety it's not until a few minutes
later after playing with sean that
codsworth yells to the couple in a panic
as the news reporter addresses to the
american people that the nuclear war has
started and the great war is about to
begin the most rational thing to do in
this situation is to rush to the vault
before nuke hits this whole section is
really interesting to look through as
there's so many people doing different
things there's a couple trying to put
their bags away in the car and another
couple is just embracing one another as
they await the impending doom for the
most part they also nailed the urgency
of this as bikes and bags are just
dropped on the ground as there are
people trying to get to the vault as
fast as possible as we cross the small
creek we make it to the gate which has
quite a long line all of these families
are stuck and are not allowed to enter
even the valtec representative from
earlier is denied thankfully since we
signed up just minutes prior we're able
to bypass the line and make it to the
vault we barely make it in the nick of
time as the nuke detonates in the
distance the couple along with all the
other survivors though do manage to
enter vault 111. this section once again
creates different feelings depending on
the player to a new player this might
feel exciting or intriguing to explore
the new vault and what it entails but to
someone familiar with the game this
sounds like a nightmare for those who
are unaware vaults in the fallout
universe were designed to shelter the
american people but were also designed
as testing labs that the higher-ups of
vault-tec could test various different
situations and see what the outcomes
were vault 111's experiment was to
unknowingly test the effects of
long-term cryogenic suspended animation
none of the vault dwellers knew of this
experiment ahead of time and were just
told to step into the cryogenic chamber
given the other vaults we've explored in
this series this one is actually quite
tame we along with our spouse and son
enter the cryopods waiting to be awoken
after an unspecified amount of time the
pods do actually open except it's not
vault-tec we see a scientist and a
mercenary talking to our spouse before
an altercation breaks out and our spouse
is shot we get a brief look at the
killer before being sent back into cryo
and then awake once again we as our
protagonist just witnessed the death of
our wife and the kidnapping of our son
and eventually discover that the vault
staff has been killed and the vault
itself has been overrun by giant rad
roaches this whole sequence while we're
in the vault is really well done and is
one of the reasons why i liked voice
acting in this game our protagonist is
not like others that we've played before
we didn't grow up 200 years after the
bombs fell we were there when it
happened so seeing a rad roach would
obviously be scary to anyone who's never
seen one before plus the voice acting
when you open up the pod is just really
great
come on
there has to be a release
come on come on come on
oh god it really displays the urgency of
nate as he tries to save his wife even
though he knows it's too late this area
serves as a tutorial for the player as
they're introduced to vats locked doors
terminals and of course the pip-boy when
they step onto the pad and get sent up
back to the surface fallout does its
classic blinding lights reveal to show
the aftermath of the bombs and how this
place was devastated by the great war
fall 3 had some wonderful environmental
design at the entrance as it showed
skeletons of those who were denied entry
and fallout 4 is the same as skeletons
of the presumed families and military we
met in the intro are just laying here it
was an even better way to showcase how
horrific this event really was as these
were our neighbors and that's a
frightening feeling after the exiting of
the vault and arriving in the
commonwealth 200 years later is where we
get to begin the game and subsequently
head into act 1. as a wrap up for the
prologue fallout 4 starts off incredibly
strong with a great cinematic opening
and wonderful introduction that
satisfied both new and old players by
giving the new players feelings of
excitement and curiosity but also giving
the old players that same feeling with a
few drops of fear not knowing when the
great war will start but knowing that
it's coming act 1 of fallout 4 opens up
the world allowing the player to go
where they please but of course for our
purposes we'll just follow the main
quest right away we have a strong
stardom regards to logical progression
as our protagonist's main motivation is
to find his son so obviously our task
will be going from place to place asking
if anyone has seen him or might know
where he was taken the first act of the
game is very reminiscent of fallout 3 as
you go from one place to another trying
to find your father except in fallout 4
it's your son the story also functions
the same way mechanically as instead of
going from one place to the next in
order you can skip the parts in between
a player who goes from sanctuary then to
all the places in order like conquered
in diamond city will have the same
outcome as someone who skips right to
the end fallout 3 did the same thing by
letting you skip right to rivet city and
i've always liked this idea on a first
playthrough you'll more than likely
follow the path the game provides but
there are a few people who may have
skipped ahead and thus got a different
playthrough they may have not met
preston garvey until hours later which
will ultimately change the way the game
plays this is also beneficial for
multiple playthroughs as logically it
makes sense that as long as you get to
the important npc in this case being
nick valentine who cares how you got
there all the npc's prior we're just
pointing you in a different direction so
whether or not you meet them is
irrelevant once again of course though
for our purposes we'll just go in order
the first person we meet after exiting
the vault is codsworth who is more than
delighted to see us codsworth has always
been a favorite of mine especially when
talking about what he's been up to for
200 years
codsworth you're acting
a little bit weird
what's wrong i
i
oh sad it's been just horrible
two centuries with no one to talk to no
one to serve
i spent the first 10
years trying to keep the floors waxed
but nothing gets out nuclear fallout
from vinyl wood
nothing
and don't get me started about the
futility of dusting a collapsed house
and the car
the car
how do you polish rust you can clearly
hear the emotion in his voice and for a
robot that's quite surprising he'll then
direct the player to concord where we
see a shootout between two groups after
clearing out the raiders on the street
we're then instructed to continue
helping as there's more inside after all
of them are dead we can meet with the
mysterious voice who is preston garvey
leader of the minutemen preston explains
that the minutemen have fallen on hard
times that he's the only minuteman left
and that the original group of settlers
he was running with had a population of
20 but it's now down to five given the
people in the group preston seems to be
the only capable soldier so it's quite
obvious how they managed to lose so many
members it's this problem that causes
him to ask for our help once again as
more raiders will arrive and we need to
drive them back he lets us know that
there's a downed vertibird on the roof
of this building but there's also a suit
of power armor and a minigun inside of
it using this should be more than enough
firepower to wipe out the raiders in
concord in fact i'd argue it's too much
firepower as a deathclaw arrives and
dies just as fast as fun as it is to run
around with a suit of power armor mowing
down dozens of raiders i feel like this
section shouldn't belong here power
armor and deathclaws have always been
seen as endgame content in the thing all
players strive for power armor will
always be the best armor in the game and
deathclaws are easily one if not the
strongest enemy in the series but
bethesda showed their hand too early
getting power armor or being able to
defeat a deathclaw felt rewarding all
the time and effort you put into
achieving this goal has been rewarded
with something but never feels like this
in fallout 4. to be fair the game does
add variance of enemies so while a
regular deathclaw might not be strong
the mythic deathclaw sure is but that's
not the point it's not about the variant
it's about the enemies themselves seeing
the super mutant behemoth at gnr and
fallout 3 is an unforgettable experience
this was a lot later in the game
compared to fallout 4 and yes while the
game also provided the player with power
armor and a heavy weapon it's a fat man
many nukes are incredibly rare compared
to the five millimeter ammo of a minigun
and fallout 3 required power armor
training which isn't accessible until
much later fallout 4 doesn't have any
power armor training and gives the
player a strong weapon with plenty of
ammo it's hours the experience of
wandering the map and accidentally
running across the deathclaw and it
sours the feeling of finally achieving
power armor for the first time it
requires no effort on the player as
bethesda wanted to give them instant
gratification and this is why i think
bethesda created the quest this way you
obviously want to hook the player into
your game so why not give them the best
set of armor in the game and a powerful
gun to go with it but what also doesn't
help this quest case is the difficulty
in how laughably easy all these
difficult enemies are within the story
and it's that part that is very
important as i'm talking strictly within
the confines of the story out in the
commonwealth these enemies can be
encountered at any point so you may have
full power armor or just a pipe pistol
the enemies are only as strong as your
gear as that is the independent variable
in this equation but within the story
it's a joke concrete is a town which
means it'll have buildings buildings
with doorways that are too small for the
deathclaw to walk through so you can
completely destroy the deathclaw without
ever taking any damage the superman
behemoths are the exact same the first
one is defeated while using the minigun
on a vertibird and the other two are
killed by liberty prime and the
brotherhood of steel ending while i
understand that bethesda wanted to hook
the players in and showcase more action
scenes to give the player a power
fantasy it just felt like this fight was
added way too early into the main quest
however despite my issues with this
fallout 4 is the first game to finally
showcase the weight of power armor it's
not just some armor you can slip on
whenever you want it's a suit of steel
and requires multiple moving parts to
work properly and while i do hate the
tediousness of having to get out to
access a workbench or how long it takes
to get in and out of the suit it's the
best version of power armor in the
series this is why i wish bethesda would
have saved this for later as both of
these discoveries would have created an
unforgettable experience and to be fair
when i first played the game i loved it
and i won't ever forget this scene but
looking back on it more critically it's
clear that this was done much better in
other entries as i said earlier at
concord we meet with preston garvey
leader of the minutemen you can continue
to talk to preston garvey as he and the
group will seek refuge's sanctuary but
we'll get to that later in the video
after conquered mama murphy tells us
that the next place to find our son is
diamond city alright look i understand
the developers needed some way to tell
the players where to go next but was it
really that hard to just have preston
tell the player that they know a
detective who specializes in this sort
of thing people like mama murphy aren't
unheard of in the series as there's the
psychers from fallout 1 and even the
forecaster from falling to vegas but
mama murphy always felt like a joke
character to me like oh mama murphy's
blabbering on again about the good old
days she must be high off the jet i
didn't think bethesda was actually going
to make her an important role in this
story it's definitely an odd nitpick to
have but i've always found this weird
once inside diamond city we can meet
with nick valentine the head of the
detective agency here in the stadium
except nick's gone missing his assistant
ellie tells us that he went out on an
investigation and never came back
obviously we need nick or we're not
going to find sean so regardless of what
situation he put himself in we have to
find him depending on where you go after
this or how long you actually stay in
diamond city an altercation may break
out it'll be here or when you meet nick
where you start learning about synths as
for the first encounter it seems to be
two brothers having a dispute with one
of them pointing a gun at the other the
brother with the gun claims that the
other is a synth and wants to kill him
as for the other encounter when we meet
nick we realize that he's not even human
allah ford does a good job of slowly
giving away information in regards to
what's going on within the game's world
is the institute they're a group of
scientists that the people of the
commonwealth see as the boogeyman the
utilizes to do most of their dirty work
as the group has three different
generations of synths generation one and
two synths are very robotic in fact nick
is a generation 2 synth and gen 3 synths
are what is causing the paranoia like
the one we see in diamond city
generation 3 synths are almost
indistinguishable from human beings this
will play into a mission later with the
brotherhood of steel but for those who
have never played this game before to
give you an idea harkness from fallout 3
and even the mayor of diamond city are
synths you might be asking how are they
since they don't look like one that's
the problem to even make a generation 3
synth the institute kidnaps people and
replaces them with a robotic body which
is why they look like humans that's
what's causing the paranoia people don't
want to be kidnapped so they're really
terrified of the institute and synth so
anyone affiliated with them will be shot
it's a really risky situation to be in
as this could mean your family is just a
synthetic robot and that's what makes
the institute such a fantastic faction
at least for now they are this infamous
folk tale with zero bases of operation
anywhere near the commonwealth so people
are confused whether or not they even
exist to begin with just like the
minutemen the institute will come into
play later so we'll hold off on their
story for now after making our way to
park street station we run into a new
gang called the trigger men they are
this little gang with a small quirk that
being that they look like 1950 mobsters
followers had this problem for years
where the developers make groups with a
different name but change very little
the fiends vipers talon company gunners
and the trigger men are all just
mercenaries or raiders with different
names there's barely any info in regards
to a proper backstory and there's never
any quests related to them that give
them any time to break free from the
others like i said it's not a fallout 4
issue it's a whole series issue but i
thought it would bring it up anyway
skinny malone is the leader of the
triggerman and he's holding nick hostage
and it's our job to break him out
assuming you survive nick will travel
back to diamond city with you so he can
help find sean and from the details we
relate to nick we discover that from
this information that a man named
kellogg might be involved this is a
small detail but i really enjoy the way
nick goes about handling the information
process he has ellie behind him writing
down information and checking prior
cases just in case anything relates to
their prior work and the way he
determines certain actions is really
well done like when he questions why
someone would just kidnap an infant
specifically and determines that it's
not a random kidnapping but rather
someone planned for this to happen
meaning someone is pulling the strings
on this operation he felt like a real
detective and even the mission after
felt like a real hunt and i've always
appreciated that back to the mission
nick is well aware of who kellogg is and
even remembers where his old residence
was in diamond city the problem is that
the door is locked the game provides
numerous ways to open the door which
i've always liked it's really nice to
give the player the freedom to complete
an objective even when it's as small as
opening a door once we get inside we
have to search for clues which leads to
the discovery of a hidden door nothing
is here but we do manage to find gwyneth
style beer in san francisco sunlight
cigars we can then use dog meat to track
his scent and hopefully that'll lead us
to him the actual trip itself was nice
and was a combination of investigation
and combat so things didn't really feel
too tedious on the way there we managed
to make it to fort hagen and discover
that kellogg is in the building we
finally come face to face with the man
himself and discover that he was working
for the institute which means the
institute had a hand in sean's
kidnapping except we still don't know
why obviously we know how this is going
to end so we fight kellogg and it's a
really tough fight he has invisibility
and his pistol is incredibly dangerous
eluding his body we can either discover
that he was a synth or at least
partially synthetic as he has mechanical
components in his inventory kellogg
sadly is very good at covering his
tracks and we once again turn up
empty-handed but due to some
brainstorming nick suggests that we can
go to the memory then the memory den is
a place in good neighbor and they have
this technology that allows you to
relive your past memories it's weird and
has definitely never explained how this
works but we've seen pods used like this
in very similar ways like operation
anchorage and tranquility lane and
fallout 3 so this isn't really too
far-fetched for the universe after dr
amari hooks us up we get glimpses into
kellogg's life where it seems that his
childhood was quite rough as he got
older he started taking on riskier jobs
to support the family and would
eventually come in contact with the
institute it's also hinted that kellogg
was given tech upgrades to prolong his
life as when he was a kid the radio
announced that five states would join to
become the ncr it's unclear when this
happened but the first leader president
eredesh became the president of the ncr
in 2189 so kellogg would be extremely
old by now which is clearly not the case
in game it's a nice detail and a really
cool discovery for those who are
familiar with the old war after being
hired by the institute kellogg was
tasked with kidnapping sean but we still
don't know why after he kidnapped sean
he would take him to his house in
diamond city before being taken by an
institute courser and given instructions
to hunt down a scientist named virgil in
the glowing sea before the memory
disappears we do discover how the
institute is able to operate as the way
to enter is via teleportation after
exiting the memory then we can talk to
nick about what we found out but we've
discovered that kellogg is now speaking
through nick this is a horrifying
discovery as it seems that in some way
kellogg is still alive but it never gets
brought up again not in the main quest
not the side quest hell nick brushes it
off when we bring it up to him this
whole plot twist starts and ends in a
few seconds so i have to ask why even
bother adding it in the first place the
only thing i can think of is that some
writer had a really good idea in mind
but it was cut and then never taken out
of the game it just shows a lack of
quality assurance at bethesda our next
objective is to find this dr virgil who
was originally employed by the institute
so if anyone knows how to teleport in
and out of the facility it's going to be
him if you're starting to think that
this game is really padding out its main
quest you'd be correct we're now
entering mission 7 and we just figured
out who's behind the kidnapping it's not
until mission 10 when we finally make it
to the institute and discover why sean
was kidnapped this is because bethesda
put all their money on the reveal of the
institute i'm going to summarize the
events of these upcoming missions rather
than extend this video longer than it
needs to be as i don't want to take up
more time than necessary so basically
after the memory then we make it to the
glowing sea meet with virgil who says we
need a coarser chip in order to teleport
we find a courser near the cit ruins
take the chip in his brain and craft a
giant teleporter use the chip as the
authorization key until we finally make
it to the institute like i said there's
a whole lot of padding in this part and
it was honestly boring me trying to
write about it so i thought a
summarization would be easier but desder
really wanted to surprise the player
with the reveal so they made this long
drawn out journey which more than likely
had the opposite effects than what they
were intending in this playthrough minus
a few side quests here and there i went
from main quest to main quest even
adding on the fact that i knew where i
was going and how to get there it still
took me around nine hours to get into
the institute keep in mind many players
will not do what i did for this
playthrough and instead dedicate tons of
time to side quests and settlements so
it could take double or triple that time
just to enter the building so the
question still remains
was it worth it
initially 100 the reveal that bethesda
was holding on to for so long is that
the leader of the institute is your son
since he was taken out of cryo after
being kidnapped he aged like a normal
human and is now a 60 year old man in
charge of the institute the big bad
boogeyman of the commonwealth the group
that presumably kidnaps people and
replaces them with robots is led by your
own son it's a fantastic twist and one i
did not see coming this also presents a
problem as it's quite obvious that the
institute will have a hand in the ending
of this game so are you willing to go
against your family and its wishes for a
different possibly better alternative
it's a great reveal and one that had me
questioning some of my future decisions
throughout the game at least for the
most part after arriving in the
institute we finally make it to the last
act of the game where all the endings
take place and it's here where fallout 4
completely falls flat fall 4 has four
different endings that are related to
the four main factions the minutemen
railroad brotherhood of steel in the
institute i'll say this now then explain
when we get to the specific factions but
the brotherhood story is quite
impressive the institutes is
underdeveloped and the railroad and
minutemen do not belong in the main
quest whatsoever firstly let's start off
on a high note with the brotherhood of
steel thought four's brotherhood of
steel is probably the most consistent
faction in the entire game they have one
goal and they stick with that goal until
the very end their goal is also clearly
stated which is to eradicate the
institute the brotherhood of steel
preserves old technology and destroys
other technology that is deemed too
powerful to be left in anyone's hands
the institute is that technology the
ability to create synthetic organisms
and being able to teleport at will while
also making breakthroughs in other
fields is grounds for blowing it up it
was clear from the moment elder maxson
spoke what the brotherhood stands for
and what they want to accomplish but i
don't even need to explain this as
maxine explains it perfectly by
attempting to play god the institute has
taken the sanctity of human life and
corrupted it beyond measure all i've
done for the brotherhood all the blood
i've spilled in our name
how can you say that about you're the
physical embodiment of what we hate most
technology that's gone too far look
around you dance
look at the scorched earth and the bones
that litter the wasteland millions
perhaps even billions died because
science outpaced man's restraint they
called it a new frontier and pushing the
envelope completely disregarding the
repercussions can't you see the same
thing is happening again you're a single
bomb in an arsenal of thousands
preparing to lay waste to what's left of
mankind
you're comparing dance to a nuclear bomb
this machine might not be a bomb but its
goal is exactly the same place it where
you want the damage done and when you
least expect it it delivers a lethal
blow without warning and without mercy a
precision strike delivered right at the
heart of the enemy how can you trust the
word of a machine that thinks it's alive
a machine that's had its mind erased its
thoughts programmed its very soul
manufactured those ethics that it's
striving to champion aren't even its own
they were artificially inserted in an
attempt to have it blend into society to
put it simply the institute made the
decision to create since because they
could rather than ask if they should
that speech of his was extremely
powerful but where maxine fails is at
the nuance as he sees all sins as bad
regardless of background or circumstance
this makes him quite simple minded and
unwilling to reanalyze his own beliefs
but it's because he's written this way
just because his worldview is idiotic
doesn't make him a poorly written
character maxine is a static character
within the story one that never changes
their views beliefs or values regardless
of what happens and it's what makes him
such a great character in this game the
brotherhood of steel's main quest will
either start when you meet paladin dance
or when you see the prydwen enter the
commonwealth for the first time and i
appreciate that this ending and other
endings blend into the game with fault
new vegas we had our one main goal which
was to kill benny after we kill him we
get introduced to yes man which is one
of the endings and then afterwards we
can walk over to the lucky 38 and start
mr house's ending but not before being
stopped by the legion in the ncr all
four factions before many have no
missions for us and then afterwards they
all come out at the same time fallout 4
attempts to make things flow more
smoothly however the brotherhood of
steel has 14 missions to accomplish in
its ending and six of them can be
completed before arriving at the
institute this goes for all the other
factions too minus the institute
obviously it was unique in welcome
change as it made the game feel a bit
more real making it seem like these
missions were just the natural
progression to what we were already
doing as you could do the endings
alongside the main quest as opposed to
just having them appear assuming we
start from the beginning we meet palette
and dance at a nearby police station who
we assist in fending off some feral
ghouls the east coast brotherhood of
steel is no stranger to recruiting
outsiders so after we showcased our
combat prowess paladin dance wants to
take us on a few missions and see if we
really have what it takes during one of
these missions we get our hands on a
deep range transmitter which dance uses
to fix the brotherhood of steel's
communication relay it's unclear if this
was the reason that prydwen was called
into the commonwealth but if it was then
it's the start of our actions having
meaning the brotherhood of steel's story
has us go through all the ranks of the
brotherhood from initiate to sentinel
each of these ranks has some sort of
reward and the missions we are given are
reflective of our rank at night paladin
and sentinel were given new paint jobs
for a power armor but also got other
upgrades like the medic pump and jetpack
the missions also get progressively more
difficult as we do simple retrieval
missions in the start like the one with
paladin dance to eventually leading the
assault on the institute it feels like
we're actually making progress within
the faction although i do understand the
criticism of this as many claimed it's
bizarre that you can go from the lowest
to the highest rank in the brotherhood
in just a couple days my only defense is
that it's simply just a game i don't
have a problem if things are sped up to
keep the game interesting what i care
about is making sure that i feel like
i'm actually progressing after the prid
win arrives is where things start to get
exciting if anyone is going to have an
aircraft it's the brotherhood of steel
but an airship is next level this is the
home of many soldiers within the
brotherhood and is under the command of
elder maxson the reveal of this caught
me by surprise a brotherhood airship was
nowhere near the top of my list of
things i would encounter in this game
the ship for the most part seems rather
realistic i've never been on an airship
but there are numerous decks dedicated
to controlling the prudent and repairing
its systems and there's even a main deck
where all the doctors vendors and cooks
all sit it seems like a place that you
could actually live in the game also
forces us to speak to some of the
leaders of the ships who were more
familiar with its inhabitants and its
layout after this is where we start to
hit the meat of the story the main goal
of this brotherhood chapter is to wipe
out the institute and the best way to do
that is with liberty prime all of the
missions after arriving at the institute
are all about building liberty prime we
attempt to recruit dr lee who was a
scientist who worked on him back in
fallout 3 we also attempt to hunt for
specific parts like a high-powered
magnet and a beryllium agitator which
will come into play later but during
this however two important quests appear
one is related to the railroad as the
brotherhood sees them as a threat to
their operation and need to be wiped out
and the other is the discovery that
palette and dance is a synth we get the
order from elder maxson and we are given
no other option but to execute him for
being a synth now obviously that's the
only option he gives us but when we do
meet with dance we can talk to him about
the situation and convince him not to
give up his own life dance can agree
with our decision and decides to just
run away from the commonwealth but
before we can see him leave elder maxson
gets to him first we have to convince
elder max and despair dance or else
we'll have no choice but to execute him
this quest was incredible and would not
have been as impactful if it was anyone
but dance he was the one who sponsored
us and is the reason we're even in the
brotherhood to begin with so the fact
that we have to kill not only a fellow
soldier but a dear friend is rather
heartbreaking it's also pushing against
maxon's belief as he thought of since as
the enemy but one of his own paladins
who did nothing to betray the
brotherhood as a synth and now has to
come to terms with the situation whether
that means killing dance and continuing
to believe all sins are bad or realizing
that not all sins have malicious intent
it is a tough decision for him but he
does stay true to his word and refuses
to see dance as a person the finale of
the brotherhood questline is exactly how
you'd expect we escort the brotherhood
and liberty prime to the cit ruins and
blow a hole in the ground that leads to
the institute we then make our way
through the institute place a fusion
charge on the faction's reactor escape
and then blow up the facility this fight
is really difficult but given that the
brotherhood of steel has soldiers geared
in full power armor this was a cakewalk
before blowing up the institute though
we do get to meet with sean before he
dies and can have one last chat which i
always thought was a nice touch we can
even talk to the synth version of sean
which we saw when we first arrived at
the institute i'm not entirely sure what
bethesda attempted to do here but my
only guess was to give the protagonist a
chance to actually raise their son as
they had originally wanted it's a cool
detail but for me personally it just
wouldn't feel the same so i've always
left him there at the institute it's
after this where we get to see the end
credits and once again i'll address that
later once we finish all the factions
our next faction is the institute we
continue where we left off in the main
quest and we discover that the head of
the institute is our son sean he knows
that we no doubt have questions and is
willing to answer any that we have from
our talk with sean we can discover that
the reason the institute had kidnapped
him back then was because he had pure
dna the radiation of the wasteland
corrupted a lot of people's dna and the
institute needed a dna sample in order
to make gen 3 synths so to have the best
chance of success they would need
someone's dna who was untouched by the
world's radiation that's why kellogg was
annoyed that he had to kill our spouse
and why he calls us the backup as just
in case sean didn't work out there's at
least another vault dweller they can use
to answer the next question which would
be why an infant and not us well it's
quite obvious that it's really easy to
corrupt or convince a child rather than
an adult especially considering at
sean's age he probably hasn't had
consciousness yet so his entire life
through his eyes has been with the
institute it's also here where sean says
that the institute is humanity's best
hope for the future and that the
institute has the commonwealth's best
interest at heart you've already
established a backstory and even a
motivation as to why the institute
exists it's also a great way of making
the faction a bit more gray as they seem
like the evilest faction in the
commonwealth but maybe working with them
we may realize that they're just simply
misunderstood however this doesn't
happen just like on the prydwen we're
tasked with meeting the division leaders
in the institute and are told to explore
the robotics facilities bioscience
advanced systems and the synth retention
bureau divisions by exploring these
areas we can see that the institute is
contradicting itself the facilities
division is about maintaining the
institute systems on a day-to-day basis
robotics is where the synths are created
the sense retention bureau is dedicated
to tracking down rogue synths bioscience
is all about maintaining the food and
water within the institute and the
advanced systems division was created to
expand their own technology like
teleportation and synth weaponry so how
does this relate to the institute having
the commonwealth's best interest at
heart it sounds like they're trying to
be as self-sufficient as possible in
fact that's exactly what they're doing
as a few missions later we're told to
find that beryllium agitator we talked
about before as that can power the
institute's nuclear reactor so now they
never need any power from the surface
with that reactor they can now be 100
self-sufficient and can now live
underground forever once again i have to
ask how does this help the commonwealth
it sounds like the institute doesn't
care about anyone above ground yet
claims to have their best interests at
heart how is that possible to this day i
still have no idea what the institute
actually wants in this game there was a
clue at one point but that plot was
completely dropped almost immediately
after the battle of bunker hill mission
we meet with sean who steps outside for
the first time and upon talking to him
he says that the commonwealth is dead
and there's no future here this sounds
like a great start to a new plot as sean
dedicated years to helping the
commonwealth only to realize it was
doomed from the start thus it caused him
to focus on just his fellow scientists
and leave the commonwealth to die except
this idea was never brought up by sean
so we can't assume that's what he's
thinking plus as we discussed earlier
the divisions within the institute only
performed tasks to benefit the institute
so saving the commonwealth was never
their plan to begin with regardless
what's more important is the present
with the commonwealth lost in the eyes
of sean what would the institute do now
will they attempt to help other places
in the united states will they take the
route of the brotherhood and instead of
helping the people directly maybe wipe
out the super mutants while they're at
it no they don't do anything the only
divisions in the institute that don't
completely benefit the facility is the
robotics lab and the synth retention
bureau they do use synths for janitorial
purposes within the facility but they
also have coursers who hunt down rogue
synths and also capture people to
replace them with sins but why they're
already self-sufficient and have no
plans of helping the commonwealth so why
bother making more sense i understand
that some of the synths are used as a
way to keep an eye on people in the
commonwealth but if they plan to stay
completely underground what's the point
do you see how confusing this is the
institute has no clear goal at all
throughout the game and even if they did
the divisions within the institute do
not mesh with that gold at all it's the
most confusing faction in this game
because no one knows what they want help
not even sean knows what he wants and
that makes this faction a complete mess
assuming you've shut your brain off
while you play the quests aren't too bad
most of them are related to making the
institute completely self-sufficient as
they collect the beryllium agitator and
hire a man named wallace who should be
useful in evolving their current systems
throughout these quests though we've
been periodically going to meet with
sean and the division leaders and it's
announced here that sean is dying of
cancer and that will be the new director
of the institute it's quite a shock to
hear this as despite the fact that he
works with the institute he's still our
son that's why we have those last words
with sean at the end of each ending as
he's slowly getting weaker and weaker
and even if we didn't blow up the
institute he probably would have died
shortly after anyway as director we
really don't get to do anything we get
to make one choice on whether or not to
upgrade the sense weapons or to mass
produce more of them but that's about it
the institute finale is where we as the
director order the synths and coursers
to attack the railroad and the
brotherhood of steel attacking the
brotherhood is actually pretty cool as
we infect the liberty prime with a virus
that caused him to self-destruct and
blow up the airport and the pridwin it
was a cool mission and the all-out war
that occurred during this quest was
pretty cool too the only quest we
haven't discussed though is the battle
of bunker hill as i wanted to save this
for last as it relates to our next
faction battle of bunker hill might be
the worst quest in the entire game for
one specific reason bethesda did not
playtest this at all one thing we
haven't mentioned but has been happening
throughout some of these missions is the
point of no return before the start of a
mission you might get a message saying
that continuing this mission will make
you an enemy to this faction should you
accept all npcs of that faction treat
you as hostile and you cannot complete
their quest and subsequent ending
however before this the faction is in
good standing with you the battle of
bunker hill is what happens when you
introduce the point of no return to late
in the game i said before that you can
do many of the factions missions before
even getting to the institute as fallout
4 blends them in seamlessly but that's
where the problem lies battle of bunker
hill doesn't have a point of no return
message because the mission includes the
brotherhood the railroad and the
institute as for the mission details and
the basement of bunker hill is four
synths given the values of each group
the institute wants you to take them
back the railroad wants to sneak them
out of the commonwealth and the
brotherhood wants to kill them it turns
into this large three scale war and on
paper it's fantastic in practice it's
[ __ ] awful since there isn't a point
of no return the player can keep good
standing with all factions so assuming
you join the railroad the institute and
the brotherhood prior to this mission
it's a three-way war where no one shoots
at you obviously any faction that is
friendly to you won't attack but if all
of them are friendly then no one attacks
you and you essentially become a
spectator it's not like this is even a
rare circumstance anyway all you have to
do is just join each group and assuming
you want to explore the commonwealth and
experience all the game has to offer
then you're going to end up in the same
predicament it's a sad excuse for a
quest and while i could dock points on
the institute for having this quest this
isn't the only faction this happens to
overall though the institute is a mess
it's a faction with lots of potential
but not a lot of development it's a
faction that has no clear goal or
motivation which is required if you're
going to not only be the antagonist of a
story but also one of the main factions
within the story we the player don't
know what the institute wants because
the institute itself doesn't know what
it wants and that's pretty embarrassing
the railroad is our third faction and is
dedicated to freeing the sins from the
institute it's a really cool concept and
one that intrigued me right away you
have to go through this long scavenger
hunt following this red trail to an old
church before putting in a code that
leads to their safe house in my opinion
the railroad does not belong as a main
quest faction and would be much more
useful as if it was used as a secondary
faction like the boomers and the great
cons of new vegas within new vegas the
boomers and great cons can be used to
help complete your mission like having
the boomers bomb hoover dam or
convincing the great khans to fight for
you they don't have a main set of
missions but can help factions that do
the railroad should have been this
faction the only problem that arises
though is the conflicting motivations
the other factions have the railroad
would not want to help the brotherhood
of steel or the institute as they go
against what they believe in i'll admit
there is definitely some holes in my
idea but regardless at the end of the
day the set of quests this group has is
terrible the first quest of the railroad
is called tradecraft where you and
deacon another member of the railroad
are to infiltrate the switchboard to
recover some technology the switchboard
was an old base for the railroad that
has been overrun by since this mission
is exactly like battle of bunker hill as
if you're allied with the institute the
synths will only focus on deacon
allowing you to walk right past them the
next mission is where things start to
get a little interesting desdemona the
leader of the railroad informs us that
there's a scientist within the institute
that has been trying to help since
escape he says that there are 13 cents
ready to escape whenever we're ready but
desdemona uses this opportunity to go
behind the sciences back and instead of
rescuing 13 cents wants to rescue all of
them in one sweep it's not a terrible
plan it's definitely risky though
desdemona says that the number one
problem the railroad face is manpower
there just isn't enough people to launch
a large-scale attack by themselves her
plan is to have the sense fight for
their freedom as the number of cents
that will join the fight should even out
the numbers once again it's incredibly
risky but maybe worth a shot to prepare
for this we need to talk with synth z114
who instructs us to kill the guards
guarding this tunnel this is so that
they can be undisturbed while the rest
of the synths craft weapons for the
upcoming rebellion however we can't just
kill the guards then start shooting as
crafting weapons takes time so z114
tells us to keep sean on our good side
so he doesn't suspect anything is wrong
this means we have to do the institute
ending until a certain point and that
certain point makes no sense to me
firstly we are shawn's father so getting
him on our side is not even a problem
and we're also technically the director
so he shouldn't even be a problem anyway
but what bothers me the most is to
complete the railroad quest we need to
help the institute perfection that
prides itself on saving since it's crazy
that we have to recapture five cents and
power the institute's nuclear reactor
before we can start our rebellion we are
literally making the institute stronger
which would then make our rebellion that
much harder even though we have done all
of that waiting to get to this part of
the quest we still can't do the
rebellion yet as we get a warning that
the brotherhood of steel is about to
invade the safe house we push the small
group of knights back but then the game
completely loses me due to the
overwhelming power of the brotherhood of
steel some of the railroad members died
including its best soldier glory so it's
basically deacon tinkertom desdemona and
us we are by far the most capable
soldier in this faction and everyone
knows this as the others are thanking us
for helping they said that without our
help they'd be dead so it's clear that
without us the railroad would be nothing
and this isn't a good thing this means
the faction can't operate smoothly
without intervention from the player
making this a bad faction i don't know
whether or not the writers gave up after
this point but they continue to run with
this as our objective is now to fight
the brotherhood of steel since they shot
first to do this we need to assault a
nearby police station that has
brotherhood members kill the soldiers
then take the vertebrae to the pridwin
the only people on this mission are
deacon tinker tom and us so once again
it's thanks to us that we got the
vertibird and this quest reaches the
ultimate peak of absurdity as the great
plan that tom and d can come up with is
for the player to blow up the prid win
alone we need to place three explosive
charges then run out of the blast zone
before we blow it up i genuinely laughed
at this plan there was no way the
writers thought a solo assault on the
prydwen was a good idea for a quest it's
just bad and there's no way to justify
it after blowing up the prydwen we
finally get to start the rebellion which
leads to the same ending as the
brotherhood of steel where we place the
fusion charge on the reactor and blow up
the institute with the added bonus that
we did rescue some synths if it feels
like we're ending this faction
discussion quite early then you're
correct as the railroad only has six
main quests in its ending which is far
less compared to the other factions the
reason behind it is that half of the
railroad's quest line is dedicated to
completing the institute questline
within those six quests though only one
or two of them are actually good given
the number of quests the faction has and
the fact that the faction literally
wouldn't exist without the player's help
it shows that this faction shouldn't be
a part of the main quest at all even
though the brotherhood of steel assault
the institute just like the railroad did
they at least are highly trained
soldiers in power armor the brotherhood
is the only faction i can see actually
standing a chance against a full-on
invasion against the institute i don't
have a problem with games making the
player the sole reason the story moves
along but when it's as bad as the
railroad it's a problem going back to
the brotherhood of steel yes we made the
high-powered magnets and found the stash
of nukes and was responsible for leading
the charge to the institute but we
didn't build liberty prime and we didn't
do all the shooting during the escort
either we had assistance every single
mission in the railroad would not be
completed if not for the player you had
to escort deacon to the switchboard you
had to be the middlemen between the
synths and the railroad you needed to
kill the guards so they could craft
their weapons and you needed to destroy
the pridwin on your own if the railroad
lost every single member in the faction
but the main character it would still be
the same faction as it was before as it
is now and that's when you know you've
gone too far our last faction is the
minimen i have the same feeling about
the minutemen that i do with the
railroad and the context that they
should be a secondary faction this one's
a bit more believable than the railroad
as the minutemen have no natural enemies
so siding with either faction wouldn't
be a problem at all all the men and men
care about are the settlers and
residents of the commonwealth they want
to protect them from super mutants
raiders and ghouls which has always made
me scratch my head as to why they were
given an ending in the first place the
minutemen start out right away with the
worst example of rewarding gameplay as
within minutes you're made the leader of
the minutemen i don't think i need to
explain how incredibly dumb this is all
we do is save preston and build a couple
settlements stuff for sanctuary and
we're already general even if we were to
ignore that we don't even get the
experience of being a general as preston
still makes all our decisions and gives
us all the quests we need to continue so
we're simply just a general by name the
minute men's main quest is a story is
not too bad as you go around helping
other settlements with their issues and
showing the people of the commonwealth
that the minimen can be trusted taking
into account actual gameplay it's pretty
boring it's a faction that is filled
with radiant quests and some of the
actual missions are locked until the
player has gotten more settlements on
their sides with just endless radiant
quests that are done and over within
five minutes after taking over four
settlements preston wants to make a move
on the castle which used to be the
faction's main base of operations the
quest is quite fun and you do get to
take down a mirelurk queen which is cool
too after a few days a woman named
ronnie will use the castle intercom to
call us and request that we meet her at
the castle she is apparently an old war
veteran of the old minutemen and want to
join up again after seeing what we've
accomplished once again a really solid
mission and we also get access to
artillery units that we can use in
combat everything is starting to go
really great until just like the
railroad it immediately nose dives our
next quest is called form ranks which is
activated by completing the quest inside
job and banished from the institute the
inside job quest is where we give
sturges a hollow tape of the institute's
network and banished from the institute
is exactly what it sounds like after
this we then have to recruit eight total
settlements before getting an emergency
distress call that the institute is
invading the castle we can then use the
settlement system to build defenses and
hopefully hold them back the castle
defense is actually really fun and can
vary in difficulty depending on how much
material you've been stockpiling for
this but the issue is that this mission
shouldn't have even happened in the
first place to complete banish from the
institute we either have to kill sean a
named scientist or unrelated to killing
things we have to pass those points of
no return we discussed before the point
of no return for the railroad quest is
on the last mission so you literally
cannot do this as an option since you're
on the last mission and there's no
turning back the brotherhood is the same
way except it's the second last mission
this is technically a viable option but
who would get to the end of the
brotherhood questline than stop
especially after doing a dozen quests
with them this leaves us with our only
option which is to kill sean or the
staff meaning we have to willingly
become enemies with the institute so
that we can finish the minutemen
questline the writers couldn't think of
a natural way to make the minutemen the
enemy of the institute so they force the
player to go out and kill someone at the
institute all so that they can continue
the quest this just shows that the
minutemen shouldn't even belong here
it's not a natural decision and is
forcing the player to do something just
to complete the main quest the cherry on
top of all of this is that numerous
times preston will ask why the institute
is attacking us like we didn't just kill
a bunch of their staff to do this
mission it's probably the laziest
faction in all of fallout 4. it's a
faction filled with radiant quests that
had to be forced into conflict by the
game itself so that they had a reason to
be included in the game bethesda tried
to give the player more options by
giving us four factions to choose from
when in actuality it's really just two
as the institute and the brotherhood of
steel are the only factions worthy of
being considered a main faction if that
wasn't already bad enough fallout 4
doesn't even bother being creative when
it comes to its ending three of the four
factions all have the same objective
which is to use the fusion charts to
blow up the institute reactor this even
continues in the end game slides but
does this somehow manage to go backwards
with fallout 4 as it has less variety
than its predecessor depending on who
goes into the purifier in fallout 3
there was a different narration it
wasn't as expansive as new vegas but it
was a start fallout 4 has a total of
five slides and only one of them can be
changed the first slide only changes
based on your ending except it's only
the institute since the minutemen
railroad and the brotherhood of steel
all have the same ending which means the
slide at the end of the game is the
exact same the narration in these slides
is also just bare bones as is just the
character talking about their family and
how they wish things were different we
don't get a single word about what the
future of the commonwealth looks like
thanks to our choice we don't know if
the brotherhood left after defeating the
institute or if the minimum became a
much larger faction after the settlers
heard of the news of their triumph we
get nothing it made this journey
completely worthless all these quests
made us feel like we were making an
actual difference when it never mattered
to begin with fallout 4 starts strong
but plummets the moment we leave the
institute and while the game is still
fun to play when it comes to gameplay
and exploration its story is awful it's
full of underdeveloped factions
contradictions and quests that at some
point make no sense at all to put it
simply fallout 4 is a complete mess
thank you all for making it this far in
the video today i usually don't like
making negative videos like this
especially when it comes to fallouts but
i feel like it needed to be said if you
want to watch other fallout content i
have videos for fallout 3 new vegas and
76 that are much more positive than this
one if not i have some other great
videos like my analysis on cyberpunk one
year after release and why prey deserved
more attention than it got as always
like the video if you enjoyed and
subscribe if you're new and of course
thank you to my returning viewers for
coming back
take care everyone
goodbye
[Music]
[Music]
you